>> HEY, JACKIE.
YOU GOING TO SNEAK INTO MATT'S
TENT AGAIN TONIGHT, AND GET
DOWN?
>> OOH!
>> SHUT UP.
WE DIDN'T HAVE LIKE FULL-ON SEX.
>> YEAH, WE MADE LOVE OVER THE
CLOTHES.
[ GROWLING ]
>> YOU GUYS HEAR THAT?
HELLO?
>> MATT, WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
>> RANDY.
FREEZE.
I THINK THAT'S A SASQUATCH.
>> YO, THAT'S BIG FOOT.
YO, I GOT TO GET A SELFIE.
>> NO, EVERYBODY STAY ABSOLUTELY
STILL.
I WATCHED A LOT OF "MONKEY
MANOR" ON DISCOVERY.
APES FEEL THREATENED BY SUDDEN
MOVEMENT.
>> ME FRIEND.
ME NICE.
NO HURT.
♪
S.
FRIENDS.
ME, YOU, THE SAME.
THE SAME.
YEAH.
[ GROWLING ]
>> OW!
WHAT THE HELL?
MATT!
>> DON'T FREAK OUT.
>> MATT, MATT.
HE WANTS TO PUT HIS FINGERS IN
MY MOUTH, MATT.
>> BRO, JUST LET HIM DO IT.
HE'S ESTABLISHING DOMINANCE.
>> OH, THEY SMELL LIKE DRIED
POO.
AM I GOING TO GET SICK?
>> LET HIM, RANDY.
GOD.
[ GAGGING ]
>> MATT, GET THE SHOTGUN OUT OF
YOUR CAR.
>> BUCKSHOT WOULD BARELY LEAVE A
MARK ON THIS THING.
HEY, LOOK.
♪♪♪
FIRE.
HOT.
WARM.
YEAH.
>> FIRE.
[ GROWLING ]
WHAT?
>> OH DAMN.
>> NO, NO!
NO!
ME STRONG.
NO, ME STRONG.
ME ALPHA.
[ GROWLING ]
YOU GO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT,
MATT?
KING KONG AIN'T GOT NOTHING
ON --
>> OOH.
>> OH, MATT.
OKAY.
>> JUST GO WITH HIM.
YOU CHALLENGED HIM, SO HE'S
SHAMING YOU NOW.
>> MATT, HE'S MAKING ME HOLD
HIS -- PART.
>> PRIMATES DO THIS.
I THINK.
IT'S VERY COMMON, MAYBE.
HE'S SHOWING HOW NONTHREATENING
YOU ARE.
>> WHAT?
NO.
OH -- HE'S PEEING ON MY HAT
MATT.
>> HE'S MARKING YOU.
THE PROCESS HAS BEGUN.
>> DON'T POST THAT.
>> OH.
PUT IT ON?
>> BRO, THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
MATT?
>> LET HIM DO IT, RANDY.
>> OH, WHAT IS THIS?
WIPING HIS ASS ON MY HAT.
>> IT WILL BE OVER BEFORE YOU
KNOW IT.
>> RANDY, CATCH!
>> BATTER UP.
MATT, HE HAS THE BAT.
♪♪♪
[ GROWLING ]
>> OH, NO.
RANDY.
HE'S --
>> RIGHT HERE.
I SLIPPED OUT THE BACK FLAP OF
THE TENT.
HE MAY HAVE A BIG FOOT, BUT I
HAVE A BIG BRAIN.
MATT.
[ APPLAUSE ]